okay so match-fixing intentionally
throwing a match for monetary gain is
one of the most controversial issues in
all of esports and last week the DOTA
community blew up with accusations of
match-fixing that was after legendary
DOTA player TI winner and current coach
xiao8 came out on stream and allegedly
said something to the effect of he would
eat [ __ ] if a certain match wasn't fixed
what's more we have proof that a major
sports betting company is looking in to
that match
[Music]
okay guys really quickly before I start
this specific investigation if you want
to see more content like this more
investigations on don't at me there's a
really easy way you can push us in that
direction if you sub to the channel if
you like this video and if you comment
below that you want more content like
this it'll actually make it happen it's
really that simple okay
so last week during the Chinese
qualifier for the upcoming starladder
dota 2 minor two teams
Aven girls and newbie faced off in a
best of three the series eventually
ended with the more well-known team the
Chinese dota mainstay newbie coming out
on top 2-1 but not before serious
accusations of match-fixing were made
now Aven girls a team of absolute
unknowns actually won the first game
they were winning the second game two
before making some plays that people are
calling questionable and eventually
losing the series 2-1 more flee
morphling know this is wiki still wants
to be pleased the stone guys it rocks
it gets one kill he's looking for the
second that's a double for a cute tiny
what have you done
floyd why are you fighting what are you
doing you used your BKB what is this
chrono well guys I am far from a dota 2
expert but even to me that play looked a
little iffy and it's far from the only
one to
what the heck just letting fly it
doesn't even have any help hello
morphing now it has to be said that any
time there's a major comeback in a game
like this and the team that loses makes
some questionable plays people are gonna
cry match-fixing sometimes they're
people who laid a few bucks on the game
and didn't get the result they wanted
but this situation is different
first of all jao ate a TI winner and
current coach of a home stream the game
and allegedly made the following
comments about that match if this match
is not fixed
I will eat [ __ ] on stream breath to have
someone as legendary as well respected
as Yao eight make a comment like that is
not something that we can take lightly
but there's more in the giant reddit
thread that was discussing whether this
was a fix or not one Reddit user brought
to everybody's attention the fact that
pinnacle a major sports and eSports
betting platform may be reviewing this
match now for those of you who don't do
a lot of sports betting pinnacle is a
major established sports betting book
and they've been around for decades the
Washington Post even once called them
quote probably the biggest and best
bookmaking operation in the world
okay now this reddit users comment about
pinnacle caught my eye so I reached out
to them about the Aven girls versus noob
match here's what they told me quote the
match in question triggered an internal
alert due to receiving a larger than
normal turnover while available for live
wagering when an alert such as this is
triggered our trade floor will notify
the integrity Department all wagers are
held as pending until a thorough
investigation of the match is completed
by our integrity department at this
point the decision of whether to settle
or cancel all wagers will be made
canceling a match in its entirety is an
extreme measure and we only take it when
we have some indication that the match
was not played on a fair basis the
matching question did indeed look
problematic but we at Pinnacle did not
see any suspicious wagering activity
therefore we settled all wagers as
normal and quote now this is really
interesting because what pinnacle is
saying
that something about this match didn't
sit right but they didn't have the
requisite evidence in terms of people
laying bets on their own platform to
take action obviously pinnacle is not
the only betting platform in the world
where you can lay money on a dota 2 game
therefore it's reasonable to conclude
that if this game was match fixed and if
people were benefiting from it they
could have used any number of gambling
sites out there to lay their bets in
fact it's more likely that again if this
is match-fixing if there are people
laying fraudulent bets on this game that
they would do so with a less reputable
betting platform one that doesn't have
the robust security and investigations
Department that pinnacle house as for
the two teams involved in the series
Aven girls lost to newbie dropped to a
lower bracket and promptly lost to
another team and we're out of the
tournament right then and there newbie
made it to the finals of the Chinese
qualifier but got three owed by the team
they faced their tea master it's pretty
iffy if we'll ever get an official
ruling on this controversy valve is
gonna stay silent until they absolutely
have to say something and I haven't
heard anything back from starladder yet
although I have reached out now for
anyone who's got to this point in the
video and is just like oh what's the big
deal call and it wasn't a major match
match fixing is one of the most damaging
things that can happen in eSports when
people throw games for monetary gain it
dissolves the competitive integrity of
the thing that we love eSports sponsors
dota 2 or Starcraft or csgo or League of
Legends and there's been many impactful
examples of this in the past look at the
iBUYPOWER scandal in csgo you guys
aren't CS heads then you might not know
that a couple kids who match fixed for a
comparatively small amount of money
basically through the entire na csgo
region into total disarray let's not
forget about Savior and then life in
StarCraft people who face serious legal
penalties for what they did to their
scene and of course in dota 3 - - has
become a meme so even though in the
grand scheme of dota this was an
inconsequential match in a qualifier for
a minor it is pair
amount that we police this kind of
activity that we make sure that no
match-fixing actually occurred and it's
my hope that valve and starladder behind
the scenes are doing all they can to
make sure that that's so okay normally
there'd be what we call an end board
here like credits like jokes or bloopers
but it is literally 10:55 a.m. on a
Thursday there's something on supreme
that I want and we have to go we have to
go copy I can't I can't do this uh uh
I'm not prepared no why would you kick
me back don't want the S logo I want
this one I want this one oh my god what
size should I get [ __ ] I don't even know
my size anymore okay it's in the card
it's in the cart
dude the shop is grayed out now it's
just this is busted okay this is this
card is still processing I'm gonna
update you guys on Twitter if I got this
W or not